this episode is brought to you by gray
block pizza gray block at 1811 Pico
Boulevard in Los Angeles I want to thank
everybody today this our 100th episode
and so I'm gonna get into it more on the
on the Monday episode but thank you so
much this is absolutely crazy I don't
really know anything that's a hundred
you know I think my grandparents the
oldest one of my grandparents was I
think ninety and I think I petted a
turtle once actually recently in Maui
and it was somebody said it might have
been a hundred or something but you
weren't supposed to pet it also because
they said it's five thousand dollars if
they see you touching it so it's pretty
much only the rich people I guess really
get to pet it because the government
charges you that and anyhow happy 100th
episode thank you guys so much for being
supportive for this long also I want to
let you know that I once stood shirtless
with Dan the man cummins overlooking the
African Serengeti and I asked him a
question about something or other and we
talked for about an hour you know he
talked about something because he that
man can really just ramble I mean he's
like just going down a beautiful just
wormhole into whatever nough sand that's
who Dan is and after the conversation I
was fulfilled to the max by whatever Dan
said to me because he knows a lot about
things you really probably don't even
know if you want to know about or not
and he has a podcast it's called time
suck and it takes you on a weekly delve
through thoroughly exploring annex and
explaining a single listener suggested
topic and and if you don't want to go
down a wormhole yourself let somebody
else do it find a topic you like each
Monday he has new episodes it's inner
it's irreverent and it's entertaining
and that's Dan Cummins the man finds
layers everything from menthol
cigarettes bees with autism historical
events Loch Ness mice mimes where are
they now paranormal encounters and
conspiracy theories times suck every
Monday the link will be below this is
episode 100 and we're happy to have a
man
who you know who wrote a book recently
called sex at dawn that I listened to
slash read with my ears he has a new
podcast as well called tangentially
speaking he is a psychologist
he's a an author as well I mean I just
beautiful I mean if if it doesn't go
well maybe yeah someone mailed that in
actually I wonder if it's the same guy
who sent me one Rives blades you see in
Texas I feel like everybody who makes a
knife is in Texas yeah yeah a guy sent
me a handmade blade the the blade itself
was made from the leaves of a suspension
on a car a different guy our guy said it
was from the bones of his grandparents
so that's the handle I think yeah yeah
so different guy but yeah actually the
blade could be um we're here with Chris
Ryan how are you today I'm good I'm good
I'm shocked though I didn't know I was
coming to a studio and this whole
professional scene oh right on yeah I
was gonna go sit in your dirty kitchen
and you never mic set up on the table
next to last night's dinner
oh man that's uh podcast normally yeah
that's true I guess
yeah and we're still I think like that
in our hearts I think we just tried to
you know show up a little bit more in
the atmosphere yeah you know I am a
little stunned by the light so I in it I
actually this is it I ended up a Matt
I've read sex at dawn I masturbated not
to the book in a big day but last night
right here was something that happened
to me last time this one that happens to
me a lot good eyes hoping we talk about
masturbation did you really yeah I
always talk about it okay and I saw you
and Rogan with your hat conversation yes
and I was like oh good there's a guy can
talk about jerking off with yeah good
let's get right into it and so here's
what happens for me sometimes if I'm
jerking off right because I know you're
you're
psychologist and a jerk-off anok Anna
Anna
yeah so tell me doctor so what happened
to me was like I tried for me I try not
to masturbate right now because I feel
like for me I become addicted to
pornography and using masturbation as an
escape from what I don't know probably
from having like some real feelings
about things or like if I start to feel
something sometimes I'll just go to
masturbation you know where I'll go to
watching pornography to kind of check
out from whatever maybe might be
possibly making me have some other
feelings that I don't want to experience
so I was done working in my kitchen and
everything I was like I'm not gonna
masturbate thank God I made it through
the day without masturbating or without
watching pornography mmm so I shut down
my computer walked to the bathroom and
then I was urinating and then I had some
thought about what was it what a great
dick I have in my hand right now got
this great dick in my hand yeah no it
could have been that I got this decent
dick you know I have a short neck my
whole you know I come from a long line
of shortened that people over here so my
dick is that sort of you know it's squat
it doesn't have the longest neck but it
shows up you know but nobody is more
important than like is it really yeah
well thank you for them because my dick
can hear that yeah um but then so next
thing you know I'm masturbated and uh
and I was done and then it was like you
and then I thought it has to read into
the toilet no that would be what's that
call when you go from urination directly
in a masturbation without leaving the
toilet being in a hurry
yeah so next thing you know next you
know I had literally masturbated and
then I felt bad and that's kind of where
I was and and so I just thought man I
just feel bad about I felt like some
sense of a negative feeling hmm and then
I was like well maybe I'll just I'll
talk to Chris about this tomorrow just
ask him about it okay all right so we're
doing therapy nobody
I have lots of thoughts but I want to
know like I guess I don't like the fact
that I feel bad about it I guess yeah
yeah well you know the first thing I
would I don't know how deeply you want
to get into this but were you raised in
a religious tradition so do you have do
you feel any sort of negative thoughts
when you have sex with a woman or I
don't know if you're straight I say yeah
I'm straight yeah I mean unless
something happens later in life you know
I could have late onset homosexuality
could happen but yeah I'm straight and I
with muscular guys like Joe Rogan strong
huh he's strong how strong is he gonna
get he can't get stronger he'll break
his own he'll break his own skeleton you
can't come on
yeah it's true yeah have you seen photos
of him when he was a young guy yeah
good-looking dude very handsome he
looked more you know yeah he looks very
Italian yeah exactly with the hair yeah
I saw a young clip that he posted
recently of him doing stand-up and it
was like wow that's him yeah and he
wasn't like as beefy by far and he was
like a more sort of normal body yeah he
could have been almost he could have
been like a Russian dancer or something
but but one that you know kind of a
lower key went that's yeah yeah Wow yeah
he's already into the the muscle phase
there yeah yeah but he would looked when
he was more of a lean guy whenever he
was nearing first 31 Comedy yeah but
yeah so then I just felt bad man I
didn't grow up with a strong religious
thing I think for me it's just I try you
know the pornography has just gotten so
strong that it's hard to fend it off
sometimes like yeah and I'll go
immediately for my imagination where it
almost evolves into a scene I could see
from porn yeah and then next thing you
know I'm watching porn if that makes any
sense so do you you watch porn for a
long time or are you just going for five
minutes and business I'm in and out yeah
I'm effective with the pool so what so
what's the negative what's the source of
the negativity I don't know if it's not
religious is there like there's
something inherently ugly about coming
or are you watching like porn that
you're ashamed of there's like
it's a really nasty and because there's
something in the porn that you're not
into what if there's no porn involved
what if you just jerked off would you
still feel bad I think if I did it
excessively I would still feel bad you
want successively like a couple times a
week I think why where do you come up
with that number I don't know I think
for some reason I think I feel like it
weakens me somehow mm-hmm you feel that
physically or on an emotional
psychological level I guess I feel it a
little bit physically but then it really
like gets deeper into like like an
emotional psychological level yeah that
I just feel like it makes me less of a
man or something sometimes hmm that's
interesting yeah I don't have any of
those associations with it I in fact I
I'm very sort of wary of
any anything that makes me question
messages that I get from my body so for
example I don't like alarm clocks I like
to wake up when I wake up I don't like
you know when I started reading all the
[ __ ] about how you have to drink eight
glasses of water a day I was immediately
like where's that coming from
that's [ __ ] who says that yeah camel
you drink when you're thirsty that's why
I don't have the sense of thirst right
eat when you're hungry I'd like every
instruction that I get from society
telling me to not trust the messages I'm
getting from my body I'm immediately I
know I know some in some cases they're
probably right but 90% of the times you
know that I've I've lived long enough
now to see that information be
discredited again and again and again
like that water thing yeah that comes
from a study that was first put out
years ago by Gatorade right and it
wasn't about drinking waters but
drinking to [ __ ] Gatorade
so it's [ __ ] there's no scientific
basis whatsoever for saying you have to
drink a certain number of glasses of
water per day how much water is in the
food you're eating how dry is the
atmosphere you're right how much he's
sweating how much
in Arizona or Maine it's totally
different exactly and and your
physiology right like some people don't
sweat some people sweat a lot it's total
[ __ ] yeah so my feeling about
masturbation is like unless there's some
you know you were alluding to earlier
like maybe there's something that's
making you feel anxious and so you jerk
off as a way to distract yourself from
solving a problem or dealing with
something in your life that's making you
unhappy I'd say that could be an issue
but to me there's it could be alcohol it
could be collecting baseball cards it
could be you know online shopping it
could be chasing [ __ ] it could be lots
of different ways to distract yourself
and masturbation actually is probably
one of the least destructive of all of
them you know yeah pulling anyone else
into your trip needs it's pretty quick
and you can get back to your life it
feels good I haven't I've never felt
guilty about jerking off Wow and a few
times a week [ __ ] dude at your age yeah
a few times a day I was jerking off like
morning night and lunch break if I could
how are you 37 38 dude come on that
shit's got to go somewhere yeah I guess
I know this is this is like yeah I don't
know why somewhere I guess I did a lot
some negative you know what you know
what sometimes I think it is and then
I'm sorry I'm not trying to push on you
I know you do give therapy to people I
wasn't like oh I don't care okay cool
yeah I asked Joe Rogan about you the
other day and he said man that guys were
just one of the best guys to talk to and
I thought that that was it made me feel
a little bit more at ease mmm just cuz I
didn't want to seem I don't know how I
wanted to seem but anyway it made me
feel very at ease I picked it up at like
I said I watched your thing and there
was a moment I didn't watch the whole
thing I think I watched done and a half
of it or something I don't who has time
to watch podcast hey out there you do
and we're glad but I was watching your
thing and there were there was a moment
where there's some about sex came up but
I could see on your face that you were
you were like there's something that was
bothering you
you said like yeah sex I don't know like
people bump against each other til they
come and look I know yeah yeah people
yeah it doesn't something about it I
think doesn't it seems primitive to me
in a way where it doesn't seem novel a
like new or novel or exciting enough to
keep doing it so much yeah and then
sometimes I think you're making me think
about this a second ago like I feel like
maybe I am afraid if I have sex you know
with somebody that I care about that I'm
gonna like really care about them you
know like maybe there's something inside
of me that there's like a fear that you
know because I have I have an easier
time having sex with someone that I
don't care about then someone that I do
and it's a huge disparity there for me
and I feel like you know I don't know
maybe that something that if I like
there's a part of me there's like a fear
inside of me that came in access
sometimes where if I have sex with
somebody that I can't really love you
know or something that I'm gonna I don't
know that it's gonna backfire somehow I
don't know but anyway I'm not trying to
be a frickin weirdo just no man we're
all dealing with that stuff there's
nothing weird about it
I I relate to that and I don't know I
don't know if you if this is stuff you
want to get into but if you lost someone
that you really were close to when you
were young that could easily create a
fear you know in my case I moved a lot
when I was a kid and so I lost friends
like a couple of years and it was hard
for me to really care about people later
in life because like I sort of had this
built-in expectation that I was going to
lose them and so the more I cared about
them no more it was gonna hurt yeah and
so I for a long time and you could argue
still in a way sort of skim across the
surface like I don't have kids
and I moved a lot physically in my adult
life you know I've kept rolling and it
was easier for me in a way because I
didn't have those deep roots you know
people be like don't you miss home and
like what home I don't have home you
know my friends are spread out all over
the world
yeah there's no place I could point to
and say that's home I couldn't even tell
you I grew up there yeah
I was there I went to three different
high schools oh man yeah so you know
maybe maybe that's happening with you
maybe there's part of you that's like
you know you cared about someone and
lost them and now it's scary to to care
about somebody else yeah
but that's good because what it means is
that you're you're still connecting your
sexuality with intimacy and I think a
lot of people especially a lot of men be
partly because of porn and what's going
on in that world
I think they've lost that connection and
once you lose it it's really hard to get
it back I mean you still you still have
it and it's still really present for you
so that's beautiful so once you meet the
person or people or you you know develop
in a way where you're comfortable being
vulnerable that way that road still open
for you that then that's gonna be
beautiful for you
yeah minutes yeah I appreciate you you
know think about some of these things
yeah it's hard for me man that [ __ ] is
just so hard for me and it's almost like
at a thing it's like a thing I can't
access you know like when you say like
though you know the I'm sure like moving
around from place to place and then you
know yeah like who knows what persona
you probably had to create to juggle
yeah being accepted immediately when you
got into a place and like you know you
probably had to become a good listener
you know well I didn't I'm that happened
much later the persona I developed when
I was a kid was the the [ __ ] pedantic
I don't need I don't need anybody I'm
smart nobody [ __ ] you guys right like
you know yeah I'm sitting at lunch alone
I'm reading this book and you know I'm
in my world
I don't care I don't have friends I
don't need friends mmm that was that guy
and then it wasn't really till I
followed that persona right through
college and then I hitchhiked to Alaska
from New York I skipped a year of
college and I decided to go to Alaska
so I hitched from New York to Alaska and
back Wow when I was in Alaska for two
months or something in the summer and on
that journey my whole life changed like
I it was actually this Memorial Day it
was 35 years ago that I got to Fairbanks
and I ate a Snickers bar and a grocery
store without paying for it and I got
busted and spent four days in prison hmm
prison not Jail right because they
didn't have jail so they put me in this
prison waiting for over Memorial Day
weekend oh but I even had all these
people who were [ __ ] great really
cool people and like they built their
own houses and they were really kind to
me took me home and me and I bet that
kindness probably really felt that did
that help kind of give you a perspective
switch yeah the their kindness their
acceptance their their generosity to me
and I you know and these are people now
I I was this pedantic you know I was
gonna go to Oxford and get a PhD and I
was mr. save the world yeah well I
really saved the world a rule the world
I just be be recognized as being really
smart and teaching and literature and I
love the literature of adventure like
Melville and Joseph Conrad all these
guys are on whaling boats and going
around the world that was the [ __ ] I
loved and so that's why I wanted to do
this adventure of my own right and but I
met all these people who were so kind to
me and and I sort of said okay now I
have stumbled into their world and
they've accepted me and helped me and
you know just incredible kindness if one
of these people had stumbled into my
world they would have been laughed at
and rejected and nobody would have
helped yeah because my genius friends
were miserable as well and not [ __ ]
they were friends but they were
miserable
hmm and their relationships are [ __ ]
up and they didn't know how to do
anything practical and I looked through
these guys and it's like okay they don't
like study these books and whatever but
their lives are great and they have good
relationships and their kids love them
and this guy's like living with this
really sexy woman and she's really into
him and he fixes his car and he made
this house and I want to be like that
guy hmm like I admire that guy and so as
a real sort of turning point in my life
you know where I was like oh I don't
want to be a college professor
know-it-all mug know-it-all yeah I'm
gonna accuse you that I can yeah yeah I
can it's totally a so that's the road I
was going down right and as you say it
was a defense mechanism it was cuz I
felt afraid and alone and so I had built
up this armor you know this pedantic I'm
smarter than everybody armor yeah Matt
did I can so relate to that I mean I
think and I what I definitely ask you
some questions about the hitchhiking but
I can relate like when I got into like
you know I'm some about almost two years
sober when I got an a a that was I think
in a way some of my hitchhiking moment
where like it was the first time like I
felt like people accepted me in a way
where I wouldn't have done the same for
them you know it was people that you
know yeah you know I'd always really had
nothing growing up but then you were
people that had even less and they
weren't you know there wasn't judgement
and it just like yeah man it just kind
of it's almost like if you took a tree
and shook it it it like in the tree I'd
never felt that before hmm and suddenly
like the the the the roots and the soil
like just vibrated a little and like Oh
things feel a little different now yeah
and that's suddenly how like it was just
a perspective switch a little bit oh wow
like the thing I've always wanted was to
feel some sort of acceptance and to feel
you know just cared about and then
that's when it started to adjust oh well
this is how if someone care about me
this way I can do this for others and
then I feel even better then hmm
when I care about somebody right and it
blew my [ __ ] mind out of the water
and my heart because I'd never
I just hadn't put it together like that
yeah so I mean if that's just 2 years
ago you're you're still opening up
you're still getting used to this yeah
yeah yeah I think I am in a lot of ways
man um that's what yeah I mean I think I
am in a lot of ways and that's why you
know I know you're friends with simon
rex and i love being around guys like
that like he's such a UH like he's been
so good to me as a friend you know like
it's almost I mean it really makes me he
didn't even realize I don't think how
like special of a person he is you know
like he's just constantly like loving
you know he is he's he's so I mean I I
know you're you're in this world of
people who are famous and they've been
in movies and they didn't this and then
it did that but Simon is one of these
guys who is so [ __ ] down-to-earth and
kind and just like a he's just such a
decent person yeah and all the movies in
the you know the stars and the hot women
he's been with and all that it's like
somehow it hasn't destroyed him yeah
that's a hell of a tackle yeah cuz it's
all the hot women literally if you're
hanging out with him you end up becoming
almost like a concierge for [ __ ] like
you're basically just no matter where
you are it's like it's baffling man I
went to a 4th of July party with him at
a Soho House in Malibu wow that's fun
it was like in its show high school it's
so much like high school there's the
cliques and there's a popular and
there's you know different and four
people don't know Soho House is like
this sort of private club yeah yeah
every member and it's right on the beach
it's in Malibu so I and it was like
hanging out with the captain of the
football team in high school was like
wow this is what it's like to be with
the cool kids I ended up with this super
model that he was seeing at the time
like sitting on my lap the whole night
and everyone's like why is she sitting
on that old dudes lap and then and then
she walked me I was like yeah
like after a while I was just like this
is my world you know like I'm not I'm
not even
yeah I'm not competing here I'm like I'm
not gonna get laid I'm not I don't even
wanted like I don't even write like this
just isn't my work have to pretend so
far outside of yourself to really be
comfortable in there and you're kind of
glad you probably aren't well I'm too
old to pretend you know I that play
you're not yeah I am I mean I don't know
where it doesn't matter where I don't
pretend I don't pretend about anything
I'm so bad like I don't even sometimes I
don't even pretend I'm not farting I
just he's like you know like oh geez I
forgot they're people here I mean I'm
sort of Harold you know so but Simon
didn't ever look if Simon takes you to
that kind of thing he never makes you
feet you're never not still the same
like you're never not just still a buddy
oh no and it feels like you two could
just be wherever he never goes so high
up to the scene that it's that he's
disconnected from the reality of like
his buddy he brought to a bar yeah yeah
and that's something that I find is just
remarkable remarkable about him yeah he
has such a big heart sometimes I don't
know if he even realizes it you know
well isn't that part of the package oh
yeah you know what I mean like I did
realize it if anyone be so cool yeah
like a woman who knows how gorgeous she
is she's not so gorgeous anymore she's
kind of annoying yeah yeah you know
there's I mean it's yeah or someone
who's you know why is like like I have
this friend who's in his mid 80s and he
sort of like my mentor I guess or you
know whatever but like if you if you
went to him and said Stanley you're so
wise he would just laugh at you you'd be
like yeah I'm just old you know Simon's
met him and that's another thing about
Simon like Simon's gone out of his way
we drove to San Diego together so he
could meet this guy oh right on yeah I
heard about that did you you drove
whenever you guys I wouldn't wake
winnebago now I have a camper van a
sprinter oh that's what it was an
awesome time Simon just bought us
awesome video oh yeah yeah yeah he just
got one I just went in there the other
day and checked it out yeah yeah he's a
special guy though man he's cool and
he's somebody I think one of the first
people in Hollywood that like
it's crazy I've had a ton of other
friends but it's like Simon's a pretty
popular guy and I have more time he
makes more time to spend with me then
yeah you know anybody yeah he comes in
we go hiking up and yeah it was over and
do uh and do yoga like it might you know
it's always yeah it's just yeah anyway
yeah he's a special guy man I'm starting
a podcast soon and he's gonna steal all
our audience I know it is hopefully it's
just audio tracks of all the
relationships he's been in brother did
you see he got this whole Megan Marco
thing I know he played it so well though
he did so well he's like even the garlic
breath so for people don't know like
apparently he went on a date with Megan
mark old 15 years ago or she's a nude
Prince of white princess Queen of
Scotland or something right yeah I don't
know something is she just married
Prince Harry yeah I guess it's like
monopoly over there so yeah yeah but
yeah but Simon used to Simon dated her
at some point
well like once they went out and and so
the newspaper like tracked him down and
got an interview and he he was just like
yeah you know she wasn't into me yeah I
was into her she wasn't into me and so
he played it beautiful yeah here he is
actor reveals how he blew chances
because of garlic likes a garlic and
he'd the funny thing is though about
Simon is uh I don't know if we'll ever
know cuz yeah he kind of took an L on
that he could have you know who knows
what happened with him in her I think
but but he kind of played the gentleman
role there yeah perfectly yeah right up
to the point of saying he thought Harry
seemed like a cool guy yeah yeah
which is the timing that is that is the
classy move it's definitely a classy
move I'm wondering how many dudes would
have been like yeah you know uh you know
we [ __ ] you know we got nasty in a
shovel or something you know
oh yeah a cutlass supreme
Oh deaf and yes but yeah he played it he
played it nice I mean but that's this is
a perfect example that's I mean that
dude is dated basically now the prince
of whatever she is you know
Rhode Island or whatever is the original
Rhode Island Britain yeah yeah speaking
of ladies I'm looking through you know I
was looking through some of your
Instagram and I saw you won an avian
award yeah
I'm very proud of that my mom had it on
her man tile yeah yeah I uh buddy of
mine and that's a porn award sorry
Farley's you don't know the adult video
and I don't know Nate nation Network
something beginning with that we get to
the end you've already busted a nut
anyway yeah it's the Oscar of porn and
you know they're all these categories
like you know best three-way best like
you know anal best you know jizz on face
I don't know they're all sorts of weird
categories you have face painting they
call it I think is that what it is yeah
but it's only one color that's the thing
the second people can start dyeing their
seat with the oils intravenously bro oh
boy oh boy
yeah so this buddy of mine was making a
movie like a high-end movie that he
wanted to be sort of a crossover like a
porn but with character development and
really well shot and an interesting plot
and all that he was kind of hoping I
think would would go a little bit
mainstream and mmm and so he asked so
the the idea was that it's this cop
what's called marriage 2.0 and the the
story is there's a young couple who are
opening up their relationship because
they've been together while they're
trying to get bored they're attracted to
other people but they really love each
other so it's a common conundrum and so
they decide okay let's [ __ ] other people
but you know talk to each other about it
and and try to do this consciously
so the woman in this couple is a
documentary filmmaker and so she's
having some issues and feeling insecure
and jealous and whatever so she decides
to make a movie within the movie where
she interviews people who are sort of
thinkers and writers about relationships
and sexuality so my Casilla and i play
ourselves the authors of sex at dawn so
there's like a stage set up I mean a
studio thing and she's interviewing us
about the book and then she starts to
cry and runs off and then the next scene
I'm in the kitchen with her and we're
having this heart-to-heart about open
relationships and get a Yeti yeah mhm
and and it was it was actually I really
enjoyed it it was interesting because
I've done so many interviews you know
sex a dog came out in 2010 and I did a
lot of press and TED Talks and CNN and
everywhere and I bet he ate more on the
horizon me it still seemed I mean I it
fit right into my present moment
yeah I'm still I mean if I wanted to I'd
be doing three or four interviews a week
yeah time out and Sheryl and then I have
a new book coming out later this year
early next year so then really that'll
but anyway the point of that is like
I've become accustomed to ignoring
cameras hmm which i think is a big part
of acting ah I see and so when we were
doing that scene in the kitchen it was
very easy for me to just focus in on her
and ignore the guys with the cameras and
the lights and you know all that and it
felt really good and after the director
was like dude you're really good at this
you should like think about acting and
it's like yeah as long as I can play
myself right
you know like Jack Nicholson like I'm
good at be a jack yeah you know yeah the
second you have to play a mother of
three
in Albuquerque actually like a gay dance
18-under is like yeah I don't think so
yeah and yeah so so so that was you guys
a scene and then that film won an award
oh so the film I think the film won some
other awards but I was nominated for an
award in a very special category
best non-sex performance so that's the
story of my life right there it's like
you kind of win you kind of lose you
know it's like you kind of want to show
it to your buddies you kinda don't it's
like you know fastest slow guy in the
race that's me I'm always at the you
know the top of the bottom category yeah
was there a moment when your friend who
was putting the the film together when
he reached out when you were thinking
wow I'm gonna get to [ __ ] one of
these things uh I didn't want to [ __ ]
one of these things right
so maybe and you didn't want to I I get
that I couldn't do it but was there a
moment at the beginning when he was
first started talking when you were like
and at least hope he asked me to [ __ ] it
well see I had worked in porn before so
this wasn't a new thing for me I I had a
job years ago when the internet was
first sort of starting in the mid 90s
and I had like logged on and I finally
figured out how to log on it of course
the first thing was like where's the
porn okay yeah yeah all of it was just
for yes yeah and it was like this is
back in the days where you'd like you'd
get to a site and you'd watch the lines
go across and like oh there's a nipple
coming up here oh there's the top of her
nipple oh my god and then it's just a
hat but you already calm just like a yet
it's like I got to start over again it
was the oh my god well yeah so anyway so
I found this site and they're beautiful
models and great photography and the
sets were really nice and all this and
then the text was in English and it was
like ridiculous English it was so bad
and so I copied it and at the bottom was
like a webmaster link or something and I
pasted it into an email and I underlined
all the mistakes and I I wrote this
email saying like you guys obviously
spend a lot of money on this website
it's really well shot in blah blah blah
but your English is really distracting
you need an online editor I happen to be
an online editor I'd never heard of
online editor
and I sent it off thinking like
nothing's gonna happen but it took me
five minutes right I get a phone call a
couple days later like can you come in
for an interview zanbar I was living in
Barcelona oh it turns out this giant
Swedish porn company had just relocated
to Barcelona called private and they
hired me to be there online their
in-house editor and translator so I saw
I'd been around porn sets a fair bit now
being around porn sets cuz that's just a
regular guy right I imagine I'm up at a
porn set dude I'm if I'm watching Pete
you know there's a bunch of people to
stand in there to see a wreck the whole
time like what is that like does it feel
more like an art I've never been in one
I've always wanted to go but I also like
I can cook yeah yeah sure it's the thing
is it's not erotic right it's not erotic
at all and that's the thing it mmm
that's Internet what a porn set I mean
orgies yeah I sex clubs like I've been
dungeons I've been in a lot of these
places damn and like a damn vault award
brah yeah well I mean after sex Adan
came out like anyone with sort of an
alternative approach to sexuality came
to you well they're very we're welcome
you know like they know our book and and
they know that we're accepting of all
these different things and we're not
going to judge anyone so we sort of have
entree into all those worlds and yeah I
mean I I've always been really
interested in sexuality anyway so I've
had I've been in a lot of weird kind of
what most normal people would consider
weird situations yeah long before sex Oh
danke
I mean I've had probably this is gonna
sound weird but I guess I've spoken
about this publicly before I probably
had at this point I don't know half a
dozen or more more men say dude whew and
I have sex with my wife that's totally
cool yeah you know I think like I'm just
not threatening they know I'm not gonna
stop I'm honest about it yeah it's all
on the surface yeah you're not gonna
beat slam dunk he might be
shooting some three-pointers you know
like from outside yeah yeah but they
don't you don't say but they might be
like yet non-threatening yeah and I'm
not gonna talk [ __ ] like right you know
I remember this this there was a woman I
was friends with the man and and the
situation came up and she and I used to
get together and you know we'd have sex
and then we'd like lie there in bed to
talk about what a great guy her husband
was literally that was that was what
happened you know so I don't know why
I'm talking about no it's it no this is
interesting and I think a lot of our
listeners and I mean even you know I
think there's definitely a thing these
days where you know people want to
venture outside they do have so many
other sexual desires that they don't
express and a lot of times it's because
of a marriage or because of you know
there might be a religious institution
that you know that they a template that
they base their marriage on which i
think is understandable you know it's
such a that's such a narrative in our
world and and it's such a it's such a
life for people you know that I think a
lot of guys are probably afraid to even
broach the subject or bring it up or
there's probably both spouses in a lot
of marriages and relationships just
laying there thinking some of the same
things yeah and that's one of the best
things that that's happened as a result
of sex at dawn that I get emails from
people saying the book enabled them to
get into a conversation and then once
they got into it as you said they found
they were thinking the same thing and it
actually enabled them to be so much
closer together you know whether they do
anything different or not right just the
fact that now we're talking about it and
we're being honest about it that can
take so much pressure off you know so
much I mean I can experience this
recently with a girl that I've been
dating and like and yeah just to be able
to communicate it yeah almost amazing
that you can't communicate sometimes
even though you're in an environment
where you're supposed to be able to
communicate well yeah you're in a
relationship supposedly with the person
you feel closest to in the world and yet
right from the beginning there are these
areas
where you're lying to each other yeah
about something really important
great really intimate yeah they all know
baby I'm not interested I'm not
attracted to other women
yeah that's [ __ ] that's [ __ ] and
it's [ __ ] when she says the same
thing to you so there you're here you
are lying to each other right about
something then of course you're
attracted to other people yeah yeah it's
like if a hot chick walks by you always
after pretend like you just like watched
a really slow bird fly by far away
there's something on my shoulder
[ __ ] I remember sitting in the this
hotel lobby in Sydney I was down in
Australia at this great conference
called the festival of Dangerous Ideas
wow that's great yeah in the Sydney
Opera House fantastic anyway
and I was sitting in this in his Lobby
and this smoking-hot woman walks by no
brog tits bouncing like it's a hell no
well in a shorter dress that you know
but they were in some sort of holster I
think they were just swaying man God
intended you know if a huge [ __ ] [ __ ]
hit me one time and not me and I died
I'd be cool with that like dammit it
killed that dude but how dope is it okay
so the woman is walking across she's why
across the lobby everybody's looking
which is what she wants and you know
like come on and I I sort of see across
the lobby there's this couple and the
dude is like pretending he's not looking
what he is and the woman the wife is
pretending that she doesn't notice that
the dudes pretending not to notice and
it's just like this shitstorm of [ __ ]
[ __ ] you know and it's like what is
the problem if your husband's alive of
course he's noticing this woman right
you're noticing this woman we're all
noticing her like are you supposed to
like not look at sunsets either cuz you
know no you're the only beautiful thing
in the world honey yeah come on like
even the clock in the lobby stop ticking
for a second like everything is just how
the reception guys like can you just
wait a minute yeah I'll get to you in a
minute sir yeah the fruit stop the
elevators
oh I've been in those environments like
the hottest woman in the world walks the
room you just like my god you know and
your tongue falls out of your mouth and
then a tongue falls out of your dick and
you're like wow my tongue falls out of
your tongue yeah all the way right up to
her eyes like a red carpet it really is
I wonder if your tongue falls out almost
as like this proverbial red carpet of
your soul and hope that this woman will
walk right up into your mouth yeah you
know with the heels
oh I'd let her yeah but yeah so we get
we feel so say in that instance the man
you know pretends he doesn't see and
then the woman pretends that he didn't
she didn't see the man see the woman and
I guess it's this it's kind of a song
and dance that we do but it's based in a
good do you think it's based from a good
place because I feel like the man's
intention was he didn't want his wife to
feel bad or his girlfriend to feel
unwanted yeah but that's treating the
symptom it's not treating the underlying
disease okay underlying disease is
feeling that your partner being
attracted to other people is an insult
to you hmm right and that's a problem so
I think if we can overcome that now of
course I'm not saying you know you're
walking down the street you like dance
on that chick like get it dude be cool
you know don't be an [ __ ] then and
same thing with women like you don't
need to like be insulting to the person
you're with right right but there's
there's no point in not acknowledging
that we're living sexual beings and we
feel attractions for other people yeah
and in fact in a couple you know if I'm
with my wife and we're walking down the
street and you know we're holding hands
and I don't see a hot woman she'll
squeeze my hand and be like it 10
o'clock 10 o'clock don't miss her like
you know she's looking out for me you
know and that makes me feel so close to
her cuz I don't have to pretend like oh
yeah she's hot but you know
yeah I I think we develop these
pathologies because of the repression
right whereas if you're not repressing
it you're not pretending you're not
lying to yourself and to your partner
then it's not a big deal like yeah she's
hot whatever great you know you can
enjoy it but it's not a problem right
like I don't want to buy every beautiful
house I see right I don't even want to
go into it I just drive on by and it's
like wow that's a nice house fun right
so I think there's our appetites get
distorted by repression it's like any
pressure you hold it in it becomes
explosive hmm you know and so those
repressions are like things whenever you
first start dating someone you say like
oh I'm not interested you know I don't I
don't think about other women or I don't
you know instead of being like you know
I love you but if I see a hot woman I'm
gonna appreciate that that would be it
would be almost unnatural be me shutting
down a natural desire within my body
right what's like I said like sunset you
see a sunset you see it of course you
see it you've got an appetite for beauty
and a capacity to recognize it how is
that a problem yeah you know and it
almost goes back to wood you were saying
earlier about yourself that you know you
anything it doesn't feel natural you try
and you stay away from exactly it's the
same that's that same thing like I'm
really suspicious of anything and we
live in a society that's constantly
telling us to distrust our appetites you
know think about a little kid well the
first thing that little kids learning is
know you eat now because now is when we
eat but I'm not hungry
doesn't matter eat oh go to bed but I'm
not tired doesn't matter go to bed wake
up I'm really sleepy not doesn't matter
wake up ignore your body ignore your
appetites ignore the wisdom that's
accumulated over millions of years of
evolution yeah you know telling you what
to eat giving you appetites for the
things they're gonna be good for you
ignore all that and do what we tell you
because margarine is better than butter
turns out margarine is totally [ __ ] but
when I was growing up you were told oh
stay away from that five fat diet
that'll kill you no actually what you're
giving me will kill me yeah
you know so the things taste good for a
reason
all right the right things are our
bodies and our I think are something
deeper our spirits our souls whatever
we're going to talk about they yearn for
connection with other people and one of
the ways that that's expressed is
through sexuality now I think because we
live in this distorting environment that
can get twisted up and and become
problematic in lots of ways
like relating to some of the stuff we
were talking about earlier like porn you
know / attention to porn or whatever or
this insel thing that's happening now
we're like dudes and high school or
shooting people because they got
rejected they're not getting laid any
time these natural appetites are
repressed and denied bad [ __ ] starts to
happen and now we when you say when you
talk about I love this this thing about
the insel like you know people you know
guys high school guys who are in the you
know more nerd cat it or not nerd but
whatever category the unwanted or they
feel undesirable yeah you know we're the
outcasts and they end up you know
shooting up a school and you know we're
taking out some type of wild activity
like that in addition to say if other
people are getting sex around them and
then at the same time there's the this
this porn that makes it seem even more
like sex should be so accessible hmm I
feel like that might be even a greater
pressure than we probably face when I
was young you just heard a rumor about
so-and-so [ __ ] and if you didn't know
him you couldn't even ask them if they
did [ __ ] you just had to assume that
like I remember in seventh grade or
sixth grade heard about two people
[ __ ] by a pool on a on a bench or
something you know which now as I've
gotten older seems way comfortable
especially in the Louisiana's summer but
but at the time I believed every second
of it whenever I saw that person I
believed it but I didn't know that boy
well enough to ask him
so that was my I only felt that one oh
I'm not as good as him maybe in that
world but now if you feel a few of those
things and then you also have this point
I'm available like sexes yes sexes say
everybody should be able to have it well
not just porn but advertising Yeah right
everything there's selling hamburgers
and trucks and beer and it's all tits
and ass and you know yeah everything's
about sex sex sex everywhere and then
they tell us also that we shouldn't look
at women a certain way now there's this
whole other movement like don't look at
women sexually but yet you've raised a
Society for the past 4050 years of
seeing sex along with you know here's
some tits with this you know blender you
know I'm saying you can't make a shake
without a bad combination without a
shake yeah that's a dangerous
combination but you can't you know it's
that bait-and-switch that advertising
has done for a long time or and then now
it's there's this huge push against
those same people who are really just
victims of advertising to say that you
can't look at women sexually no it's
it's there's a lot going on there is
there is and I think the suffering of
the teenage male who is not able to
connect with women is is a huge problem
that isn't getting talked about I mean
now with the insel it's starting to be
talked about but still not with any kind
of sympathy or understanding and and
look just to be clear I'm not saying
that this is the fault of women I'm
certainly not no it doesn't sound like
that at all I don't think anyone's
taking like that if they are they're out
of their mind yeah but it's important to
say that because I think women you know
historically get blamed for a lot that
they're as much victims of or more
victims
you know like promiscuity you know in
sexathon we argue that we evolved to be
pretty promiscuous species which is
evident in you don't so much everywhere
but a lot of times people would be like
you know well why aren't women more
relaxed about sex then why don't why
aren't women you know just more openly
just [ __ ] whoever they want well how
about because for thousands of years
they've been burned at the stake for
doing that for doing that for even down
walking about it yeah yeah or cured like
left to starve in the streets right you
dirty [ __ ] get the [ __ ] out of my house
you
looked at another man you know it's like
the women have have for thousands of
years had to deal with incredible
oppression they've taken the brunt of
evolution in a lot of ways well I'm not
even talking about evolution I'm talking
about culture okay yeah they've taken
the brunt of yeah what have they taken
the brunt of yeah it's like whenever
there's something it they the women have
put up with a lot yeah yeah so when I
talk about the frustration of teenage
boys who can't connect to women yeah
that's why I'm very careful saying I'm
not blaming the women I get it
but it is a problem it and I think
there's a lot of rage because and it's
not just sex I mean hey if there's
nothing hornier than a fourteen-year-old
boy yeah oh I put one in my [ __ ] dick
right now if I could just to help me I
drink the blood of one bro yeah well
they used to they used to like take the
testicles of chimpanzees and grind them
up and then inject that into men's
testicles damn yeah yeah if you want a
weird [ __ ] to try to get horny one dude
I would hide one in my ass maybe I'm not
shooting one into my nuts with a needle
you hide a fourteen-year-old boy a
couple chimpanzees not some - my hand -
yes ring to me come on cialis right now
from India I'm buying that [ __ ] makes my
leg sweat but it makes me feel alert no
wait a minute you're you're you're
bumming out cuz you're jerking off three
times a week but you're taking Cialis if
I mean if I want to be sexually involved
or feel that way you know I really as
sometimes I have to just I'll pop one
just to feel that extra adventure when
I'm walking around town you know that's
for adventure yeah cuz I don't bone me
when I was young I used to bone up like
a dam you know like somebody looking for
nickels at the beach you know but now I
just don't did it beep - I think it
could whistle but now I don't get that
anymore you know I just don't
and I don't get it in LA that much
there's so much going on here yeah dad
I'm and I feel like I'm hyper aware
sometimes and it might feel a constant
anxiety when I'm here but the second I
landed in any other city man I mean it
could be Toledo and I'll [ __ ] be
erect right when we hit the runway and
you get a Toledo heart yeah I think
that's the name of the roller derby team
it's a name of a steak that sir they're
well duh yeah but now I want to get back
to some of the stuff you were talking
about with the young men I think there's
another element there and this is just
that a lot of young men were raised out
of split parents and so the thing does
this weird connection to where a lot of
men looked at their mothers as fathers
as well or something and so there's an
element there I'm finding in my
generation where even you know in their
30s a lot of men are having trouble with
women and we noticed it even just from
the podcast man so many yeah guys
reaching out like addicted to masturbate
addicted a point-like or at least they
feel they are yeah and you see it in
like jordan peterson sam harris joe
rogan me you Duncan
like I think the podcast world a lot of
what's going on there is a lot of the
audience is young people and I think
disproportionately men looking for some
sort of guidance because as you say they
didn't have a father figure in the house
and there's a big hunger for that
justifiably so and I think it's it's you
know when when somebody acknowledges
their vulnerability that's such a strong
thing to do you know
amen so you know people who are doing
that who are reaching out to you or Joe
or me or whatever I always really
respect that because it's like until you
know you need something you until you
know like that you're missing something
then you're just an [ __ ] yeah you
know you're just running around thinking
you got to figure it out doing damage
but once you stop and say oh wait a
minute
I gotta stop and think about this and
ask somebody for help that's a really
important moment in your life yeah I
mean that's so yeah you say that
vulnerability that ask them for somebody
for help I remember yeah I mean I still
noticed just how huge that is now like
even if if I'm having a moment with
somewhere I feel like I don't want to
tell them some something to then like
take a moment and actually share
whatever that is you know that feeling
you know like you know right now I'm
upset and you know the reason why is
this instead of just leaving the house
and you know that old-fashioned I'm you
know caveman run out of the house and
hold it all in that vulnerability it's
amazing how I never in my life knew how
to be vulnerable I just didn't even know
you could write I felt probably
vulnerable you know but I just never
knew how to you know even tell a woman
like look um you know I feel nervous or
I feel this way you know or to show up
be one of you go to talk to a girl that
you think is attractive be like I
[ __ ] you know usually if I saw a
girls track these you I just go you know
jerk off in my car but I'm trying to
come over and say hey this time yeah
just vulnerability is huge and the thing
that that young men don't understand I
certainly didn't understand when I was
young
is that like women are way ahead of us
in a lot of ways and one of them is that
I feel like I'm listening to the book
right now this is so crazy I just at
that moment just cuz hear voice
ahhh-ahh-oh right oh yeah I know Rocky
though and one of them is one of them is
that women in not all women but a lot of
women are deeply attracted to vulnerable
men like not I'm not telling you like
cry you know like yeah all the time but
I have found that women like like I get
a lot of emails from people saying oh I
could my girlfriend would never accept
like you know I can't talk about this
stuff with her right the thing is I also
get those emails from women saying I
wish my boyfriend would be more honest
with me I wish he'd tell me you know the
thing is when you're really honest and
vulnerable with a woman it makes her
feel safe
because she knows your your real yes and
she can trust you
yes and that you're not thinking
something that you're not gonna say
you're not hiding things that's what
women are really afraid of he's like
what are you hiding what's going on what
what do you have in your pocket that's
gonna come out and stab me in the back
you know yeah and so if they meet a guy
who's like look I mean when I when I met
Casilla I laid some [ __ ] out on the
table to her about you know being
attracted to other women and stuff and
she said to me she looked at me and she
said you know I grew up in Africa I've
been a psychiatrist for 10 years or
whatever it was and I know how men are I
know how the world is but you're the
first man who's ever had the balls to
tell me that mmm right like she knew it
she knew everything most women know how
men are they know how we think they know
but the fact that I said it out loud and
I said it to her early and I was like
look you know here's here's who I am you
got to know this if that established a
basis for our relationship we're still
together 20 years later and I think that
women will forgive and men too I think
will forgive a lot more than we than we
think if they know you're being honest
with them if they know you're being
straight and they don't need to worry
about what you're not telling them you
know no III couldn't agree with you more
I couldn't agree with you more I mean
I've spent I've spent relationships in
the past just hiding the truth and like
you know things that I you know I was
you know cheating or lying or running
around these with other women but I
still was in love with the person that I
was with but and then that made it that
made everything else so complicated yeah
cuz then every time I looked at my
girlfriend I had these lies and inside
of me and so it it just created and then
I would book gonna resent her for not
even knowing I was a liar right at some
point which is so baffling it was like
you know just what a sickness it all
become yeah yeah but how does a man who
had a relation who has a really who's in
a relationship now and they see
you know that they they wish they could
be more honest is there a way for some
of these guys to kind of backtrack or
women because we do have a lot of female
listeners as well for them to backtrack
in and get into a more comfortable space
well yeah I mean it it's harder when
you're already in the relationship to
sort of go back and re-establish where
you are but I think a lot of people do
that and and I think you know what I say
to people is figure out what your
non-negotiables are and then don't
negotiate I think that's a mistake that
a lot of people make so if you're
already in the relationship then the
question I have is do you have kids if
you have kids they really kind of have
to be the top priority 100 percent so
then it's about okay how do we keep this
ship afloat as you know until these kids
are up and out on their own or whatever
the best we can do but if you're in a
relationship and you don't have kids
then it's like you know take some MDMA
and have a go for a hike yeah go camping
and get real with each other yeah go sit
by the beach goat sit by a campfire get
away from all the distractions and yeah
lay your [ __ ] out you know and and
because I mean it's so funny we the way
we live our lives it's like oh I want to
be with you for the rest of my life but
I don't want you to really know who I am
well what the [ __ ] kind of relationship
is that you're gonna spend your whole
life with someone who doesn't know you
really that's what you want to do why
cuz you're so ugly that you're afraid if
they know you that they'll leave you
yeah well I Got News for you they're
thinking the same thing and there's no
more beautiful moment than when you show
the thing that you're afraid of to
someone and they're like yeah I knew
that was there I love you anyway man of
course that's that's a relationship
that's and that's real love that's real
love exactly yeah I had a moment with my
mother I think where I realized by
that no matter what she ever did me or
whatever I thought she did or even
things that or however our relationship
was that I loved her in spite of that
hmm and I'd never had that thought
before like my whole life had always you
know I think I still battle with a lot
of things because you know my father was
70 when I was born you know my mother
was working all the time there just
wasn't you know a lot of disconnection
things that were there's that almost
just built into the fabric of me you
know but I don't think I'd always held
those things against her or put them on
opposite sides of the scale of my love
for her hmm so one kind of had to be
balancing the other or something and and
this was the first time I ever thought
that you know and I said to her I said
look you know no matter what ever has
happened between us or even that I've
thought has happened you know that I
love you no matter what you ever did to
me or I thought you ever did to me and
that was like one of the greatest
moments I ever had in my life mm-hmm and
I didn't know I could even have that
right but it was like the scariest thing
for me to say that I would love somebody
even if they hurt me right or I thought
they did right and and it was powerful
for her too because I'm sure if she's
probably has thought in her life that
she didn't do good enough because I bet
a lot of parents feel that all of them
yeah yeah and it's but it goes back to
vulnerability just like uh I don't know
I don't know why I brought that up well
I you know unconditional love and
acceptance yes
also there's a difference you know
talking about romantic love there's a
difference between loving someone and
being in love with someone and I think
we tend to conflate that and give those
things mixed up it can you tell me a
little bit more about that because I
feel like I could have some trouble with
that yeah you know I think being in love
is that you know we say falling in love
in English in Spanish they're two words
for love there's takedo and teamö and
takedo literally means I want
it's about desire possession you know
you want to be with them all the time
you you just want to [ __ ] all the time I
got Amba exactly that kind of love
but then that wears away that burns off
you know and then then you find out if
you love the person or not my problem is
that you know people are making these
major decisions on their lives like who
they're gonna have kids with and live
with them introduce to all their friends
and all that based upon that I got a
drunkness yeah you know that yeah oh
she's so hot and you know I love the way
she smiles and you know what he's got a
great job and a great sense of humor and
whatever and then you get past that
stuff and it's like oh you're just a
person I'm just a person now we figure
out if we respect each other and if we
actually want to hang out you know
so that's love and that's what's left
when that other [ __ ] burns away if if it
was ever there to begin with right and
so there's there's this book called the
erotic mind by Jack Morin that probably
came out in the 70s or 80s I remember
there's a is that recommended reading by
you well yeah I don't really remember
the book to be honest I just remember
this one this one formula in it so I
can't really recommend the book because
this is all I remember from it but he
says attraction plus an obstacle equals
passion mmm so you think of every love
story it's I want to be with you but
you're are you're married yeah you're
from another religion you're in a high
tower yeah exactly your parents our
parents won't let us we have classes or
different races and we're in the south
and you know whatever and so that
obstacle builds up it takes this desire
where if there were no obstacle it might
be like yeah you went out and whenever
she's cool but yeah it's just a
long-haired girl that lives on the first
floor exactly exactly but it turns into
giant love story because of the obstacle
yeah so what do we do so you meet let's
say you meet the woman in your dream she
lives in New York and you're in LA and
no kneeling you see chopper right now
now there's an obstacle it's really hot
and you can't wait to see her and you
schedule your tour so you can be where
she is and you did other stuff and then
eventually get to the point where like
you know let's move in together and so
she moves out to LA and and now you're
living together and six months later
it's like [ __ ] what did I do
yeah what have I done you're hanging out
with the plants instead of her yeah my
life was so good before it started a
garden you removed the obstacle yeah so
are you saying that it's better than to
keep an obstacle in the relationship at
all times if that is that one element
that we can use to help our
relationships or and I know you're not
saying I know we're just thinking but or
are you thinking that maybe the
alternative to that is is a different a
different path where there's a love
first a reality first and then the sex
comes but it's kind of tertiary to that
well I'm what I'm saying is that it's
the nature of existence for the passion
to evaporate when you've removed the
obstacle and so you can't blame that
like a lot of people get together and
the sex is really good that's super hot
and then four years later it's like it's
kind of worn out they're not and they
they say of this relationship this isn't
the right guy this isn't the right woman
this relationship isn't as good as I
thought it was that's not necessarily
true what's happened is that you've just
you know you're a certain kind of animal
and you get bored and it's not that
doesn't mean that that's not a good guy
or a good woman or a good relationship
it just means you're Homo sapiens right
like if you ate Thai food every night
for the rest of your life after a while
you'd be like [ __ ] again right yeah
that doesn't mean Thai foods not good
it's my favorite food in the world but I
wouldn't want to eat it every night so
like doing magic like I try to do a
magic for a while and after a while like
[ __ ] magic day
you know [ __ ] magic yeah I mean it's our
point yeah that's who you're saying so
it's like yeah you wear it out the
fascination now that doesn't mean it's
not the person's not cool right so what
I'm saying is understand that understand
that and don't blame yourself or her or
write or if you want to maintain that
then yeah you got to keep an obstacle
then say alright we're gonna have a long
distance relationship or we're gonna
vacations separately like learn like
miss each other sometimes yeah you know
don't work together don't don't be
together all the time even though that's
what it feels like you want to do that's
a disaster that's you know it's you need
resistance you workout you need
resistance you need to lift away yeah
pushing on something and I struggle with
that at times there are moments when I'm
needy when I feel needy and I will
instead of like experiencing some of
that need or that desire or letting it
build up or may or you know even for
that person I'll immediately call them
or immediately text them and it kind of
takes a little bit of valve off of the
overall desire for them
and I think in a weird way that now I'm
thinking about it might be what happens
to me sometimes sexually like I'm afraid
to let my sexual desires build up
because maybe I'm afraid of you know
what'll happen then like I'm not
thinking I'm gonna be a rapist or
nothing like that but I'm just thinking
that I might you know create a stronger
bond with a woman that I really care
about you know so I think maybe that's
sometimes I've never really thought
about it but that could be some of the
reason why you know go to pornography or
find an outlet you know masturbate or
something and I know I'm you know I
don't mean to keep coming back to my
case but I just I noticed that I have an
unhealthy relationship with it and so
I'm still in the search of kind of
figuring out what some of that is you
know right and I'm okay with it because
I am you know I'm opening to learning
and I'm you know taking on new ideas
yeah I did want to ask you about
hitchhiking man if you don't mind I know
it's a full circle but brother yeah I
was the ride you know sometimes you
don't know where the rides get a guy
yeah
yeah I think I was like the last of the
hitchhikers you know nobody hitchhikes
anymore
he probably man there's one left and
it's a dude alright I'll take him
it's like me and guys who just got out
of prison are the only people out there
do you do you think we lose we lost
something by not having those days what
was that like I mean you threw the thumb
up or you were hearing people at truck
stop sir no I just said stood on the
side of the road you know that did it
recently actually that the director
James Franco if I wouldn't be surprised
but know this this guy who did pink
flamingos and faster pussycat kill kill
kill he's from Baltimore John Waters
yeah he hitchhiked across the country
and then he wrote a book about it in
animation no he's a film that Roger
water something Rogers John Waters is a
homosexual yeah yeah yeah yeah really
cool guys Wow yeah people say he's the
best sorry - Mina describe him just as a
homosexual man yeah he's an artist
yeah producer he's ago hater and his
films are like flamboyantly kind of
campy yeh yeah it's not like he hides it
or anything
he's Palm Springs he's like the mayor of
Palm Springs so is he I don't know if he
is but everywhere you go there everybody
says they know him uh yeah but um anyhow
go on yeah he did it so he had tried to
cross the country yeah Wow yeah and I
remember like a van of like musicians on
tour picked him up they drove by him and
they're like that was [ __ ] John Waters
like what we backed off and he go like
your dad why are they good yeah so a lot
of people picked I didn't know who he
was though yeah so you just you think
the in fancy umbrella would be a dead
giveaway the Cape but yeah what how
fascinating was it fat were you did you
find there was more fear by the pickup
er or by you well I think if they were
afraid that him they didn't stop so I I
don't remember many people being afraid
of me if they were afraid they didn't
stop that's a good yeah
no-one's like I'm so [ __ ] scared let
me stop and open my door yeah
for a rollercoaster I'm gonna pick up a
hitchhiker yeah you're making a
commitment to I mean I I'm we hitchhiked
I met so I hitchhiked from New York to
Seattle the first year I did this twice
two years in a row so I went from New
York to Seattle and then I took the this
Alaskan ferry up the Inside Passage -
and that's not another John Waters
reference either guys the inside passage
ya know the Alaskan ferry oh sorry
both work and now so the ferry was that
so that was more of just kind of a
traveling thing it wasn't a hitchhike
hitchhike - you don't know no no I just
paid and you could camp out on the on
the deck we have like a cover it was
amazing and the Stars you must've seen
must have been well yeah didn't see a
lot of stars cuz it doesn't really get
dark in Alaska in the song so but orcas
and bears and bald eagles everywhere
it's really nice so up the there's like
four or five days up the inside passage
and then you get off it either Haines or
Skagway and then hitchhike up through
the Yukon and then across to Fairbanks
and then down to Kenai and different
places I went Seward in different places
so it's a long [ __ ] hitch and it's a
manly Trek - I mean that's a lot of you
know you're seeing a lot of animals
you're seeing a lot of nature
you don't imagine at that time you say
there's kind of a transformative time
but there's also this this ambiance of
that you're not alone in the universe
there's other animals there's you know
and that's a manly Trek that's ice cold
out there not in the summer yeah in the
summer it's pretty warm but yeah I mean
they're bears around and you got to have
all your food with you you got a tangia
sleeping bag you got you know you gotta
take care of yourself it was a rite of
passage for me it was good and then yeah
and then coming back I took the train
across Canada one year and then I
hitched from Montreal down to New York
to see this woman that was a weird one I
was coming down through the Adirondacks
and and like in the middle of nowhere
and it was
getting dark and I'm starting to think
you know okay I'm gonna like another 20
minutes and I'm gonna go you know find a
place to crash in the woods here and
this guy stops mmm and I get in the car
and the dudes like big muscles tats
crew-cut ex-military looking guy and I
always had this like I wore jeans and I
had these Nambu --ts and I had a knife
inside my boot under my jeans and my
right leg just cuz it seemed like
everybody's perfectly if [ __ ] got weird
you know I'm sitting there and I can
just easy you know tie Kevin open like
hold on let me get a knife and opening
your bag yeah no no yeah can I get in
the truck
and I never I never had to use it I
never pulled it out but it was just like
if somebody if things got really weird
had I had it you know something anyway
so I get in this car and there's a
little small talk with this dude and you
know where you going right where he was
in Alaska and and he's like yeah yeah
okay says so you like knives like that
and I was like yeah like damn knives are
cool and he said I noticed you have one
in your right boot Wow
[Music]
something you feel like a murderer well
I feel like I'm about to get murdered
maybe like how did he know I have a
knife in my right boot like it's under
my jeans maybe he was really like maybe
he could smell knives I guess so I'm
like I say well it's just I'm
hitchhiking I just something you know
and he's like yeah it's cool that's cool
and he grabs his belt buckle he's got
this big belt buckle a pulse and there's
a knife now it's a handle of a knife
then and the blades like under his belt
and he goes like that and he's holding
it right in front of my face this
[ __ ] like six inch dagger he thought
you were dead I'm like yeah I'm getting
dying now cuz I'm in the middle of
nowhere
Suns going down
cars anywhere there people down long
yeah he might dump my body anywhere yeah
he fivin riding every 90 hey finally got
another one anyway so this is nice right
in front of me and I say that's that's a
nice knife he says yeah and I said can I
hold it and he's like yeah go ahead oh
and I took it and I was like that's
beautiful man I'd give it back to him he
puts it back he says yeah I got another
one here he's got like three knives on
his BA my god
turns out this dude was a prison warden
there's a high-security prison up there
and he was a warden and so when he saw
me on the side of the road he scanned me
and immediately saw a bulge in my jeans
you know and he's like yeah that's what
he does for a living you know and that
that was an important experience for me
because it made it clear to me that uh
that the the the knife was not gonna
save me the knife was gonna get me in
trouble and that there were like I was
an amateur and they're pros they're pros
and before you'd always thought you were
the pro I thought I got a secret yeah
and it turns out no dude you don't have
a secret like if you're dealing with
someone where you would need a weapon
the chances are you're dealing with
someone who's five steps ahead of you
Wow and you know it's like lying to cops
like a detective not a guy pulled you
over you know so be right detectives
spent all your day being lied to you
you know they you're not gonna [ __ ]
you know it doesn't matter if you're
smarter than him he does that for a
living you don't it's like get into a
fistfight with Joe Rogan like it's not
gonna go well yeah you know it's just
not gonna happen it's so funny ermazi I
recently got pulled over and since I
quit drinking and doing drugs for now I
it almost made me feel cool to get
pulled over as like 130 more the cops
stopped me he walked it you're actually
innocent yeah well she walked up and
also I was like I was breaking the law a
little bit like before always felt like
I was breaking the law but now I'm like
oh cool it's pretty cool he pulled me
over and
you know thanks you know kind of give me
a little bit of study credit and then
can we do a selfie yeah yeah but then I
said when she came back she'd ripped me
this ticket and I think it was a woman
you know it's kind of one of those kind
of you know wild cops you know but and I
said how did you know I wasn't drunk you
know I said I just haven't drank for a
few years I said how do you know I'm
just curious she goes I hear what I've
ever been around to me this drunk I said
yeah she goes that's what it's like we
know it's like you know most of the time
you can tell yeah she's like it's not
that big of a crazy mystery you know and
that put it in perspective for me I was
like oh wow this whole time as it when
I've been drinking and driving I was
like oh I'm playing this big secretive
game but really it's so obvious yeah and
it's not it is not exactly what you're
saying but I can I can understand as a
young man we like oh I got some growing
up to do because there's some real men
out here well it is like you think
that's sort of the essence of being
young and maybe being drunk is thinking
you're getting away with [ __ ] and that
the people around you yes they're just
being nice you know they're just not
calling you on your [ __ ] but
everyone knows it that's so the essence
of being young yeah it's so the essence
of it you think you're pulling it just
even like in front of people that
already know I'm talking about that like
being innocent and how like exciting
that could be sometimes I just did this
road trip to New Orleans and back well
nice in the van knowed all across Texas
and it occurred to me driving across
Texas is like I don't have any weed in
this car like this might be the first
time in my life that I've ever driven
across Texas with like they could pull
me over they could search the car they
wouldn't find anything it's amazing it
almost felt like a wasted opportunity
you know yeah but it video but but at
the same time you were almost so much
more advanced than you probably have
been 20 years ago when you would have
had all the drugs or whatever yeah I
guess no but I mean that 20 year old me
is your 30 year old me's like a little
disappointed yeah I went through
Heathrow recent recently family
that's fair that's a halt again on that
one
and man they it was a weird thing the
the you know put my bag through this
thing and then they're like okay you're
gonna wait over there and then they I
saw them talking and then they took it
and they put it through another one a
line the security line that was closed
down they put it through that machine
and then he came back and talked some
more and then they did something else I
think and this guy comes over to me he's
like you and I have to have a
conversation yeah he's like what are
your hobbies like hobbies and that's a
trick question of them yeah you know but
they can whine see the thing is I'm like
I was like you and you got pulled over
I'm like I know there are no drugs in
that bag yeah I know
like there's absolutely nothing that is
gonna cause a problem yeah and even if
like there's some misunderstanding you
google me I'm like a semi-famous author
or with a PhD like I'm not a terrorist
right so whatever it is you suspect he's
not real so I felt really relaxed you
know and this is just like oh this is
gonna be an experience and so he's like
hobbies I was like I don't really have
any hobbies he's like well what do you
do you know when you know what do you do
for a living I was like yeah right I'm a
psychologist it's like what do you do
when you're not working I was like dude
like I'm 56 years old a jerk-off I go to
bed like literally said that and he
didn't laugh maybe you have half a
muffin a muffin talk just the top
because I like it crispy but he so he's
not laughing and and then he's like you
do work with animals no you garden no I
don't [ __ ] garden I used to grow weed
you know years ago who is this guy huh
very curious well he's the security dude
right and then he says well we're gonna
have to call the police because you
didn't give me what I need I was like
what are you talking about he's like
well we found nitrates on your bag and
they're used for explosives and
sometimes they're in fertilizer but you
don't
ardan you don't work with animals so we
gotta call the cops call the cops dude
but you know you're wrong he says the
machines never wrong this time dude so
five minutes later I'm surrounded by
nine like cops in body armor and you're
out Helen everybody at the airport yeah
probably embarrassing [ __ ] rounded I
know I felt like [ __ ] Jason Bourne I
wanted to start throwing kicks and like
run for it you should have just gonna
kick into the air just a little Bruce
Lee [ __ ] going on there yeah it was
crazy and then they they and they did
the whole thing we're like they're
talking they're over there murmuring and
the dudes are watching me and then like
one dudes up in my face like you know
you know what fight were you on and
where are you from and what are you
doing and they're like being a dick and
then he goes away and then this other
guy stand there and he's like yeah don't
worry he gets a little intense somehow
yeah the nice guy good cop back exactly
I said like oh you're the good cop he's
like yeah okay you got me as like yeah
at least you're not American cops cuz
I'd be like oh yeah bruised paint you
black and shoot you - some of them but
some of them won't exact yeah man it's
alarming dude and plus TSA airport
security is also [ __ ] baffling
sometimes like what are we even Abdullah
door it's not real it's usually like
there's one black bee trying to [ __ ] all
the other chicks at work there you know
there's like kind of like somebody who's
like a man and a woman and isn't telling
anybody you know because he's gonna keep
it a secret to himself there's one
little gay black guy told me had a small
dick one time and I went through there
really you can't say anything because if
the second you speak up you're when you
got patted down on a jail yeah he goes I
would seem like a smile day I was like
wow did you say that and then he acted
like he didn't say it and I know I heard
it because I've never heard that in my
life you know I've heard oh your dick
seems decent you know but I've never
heard you oh he oh you gotta seem like a
small dick you know I think that money
Ben come on oh well I mean it yeah it
could have been but it's like you can't
say anything to those people and half of
them you know quit school or used to
play basketball with and you're like
what the [ __ ] yeah they're making nine
bucks
or and they're furious some of them want
the world to end you know one guy had
this anarchist patch on one time on his
thing I'm like that's I know that sign
it was like this so who know what the
[ __ ] what airports you going through man
just local I mean just you know
sometimes out of all Long Beach
mm-hmm so that could be it Long Beach
we're open Louisiana yeah I grew up in
Louisiana some thumb I'm a lot of stoked
to hear that you went out of New Orleans
first time I ever been there in my life
and they would love you there I feel
like you would fit in so well I liked I
liked it I liked New Orleans but you
know what I actually liked the sort of
surrounding area more than New Orleans
yeah we stopped I forget there's this
long bridge it's like 20 mile long
bridge it just sort of like goes right
up above the swamp
yeah chaf Alaia basin maybe or yeah I
like Pontchartrain one of the other hfih
Wyatt Empire yeah yeah and we stopped we
stopped and somebody told us about some
restaurant and we drove to this
restaurant and we got in there and just
as the the zydeco band was warming up
perfect dance and it was great it was a
middle of [ __ ] nowhere yeah and they
were the nicest people and the owner
comes over he's like I saw your you got
a van out there where you guys camp in
and I said I don't we haven't decided he
said well you're welcome to stay here
I've got showers in the back you know
hook you up and you know like just super
nice people yeah man it was great yeah
yeah it's crazy it's so much like so
many times we've brand a lot of America
as like you know racist and angry and
all this stuff and I don't find a lot of
that I mean I find you can find some of
that if you're looking forward if you're
reading articles you can find a lot of
that but I find a lot of times when you
get out and you spend time with people
that you know yeah they're dealing with
some things a lot of times and I think
we have some overall issues in America
that are you know historical but I find
that people are usually fun and I don't
mean ago brought on that but but
Louisiana's a fun place man and what the
biggest thing they have there is just is
tour you know any type of tourists
people want to they want to show you
Louisiana there's this thing they want
you to know love it yeah there's a lot
to love I mean that's an interesting
like ecosystem to
yeah yeah yeah yeah it is I mean you
know we didn't go out on any boats or
anything next time I'm down there I'd
like to do that and go on the swamps and
check it out dude I'd love to go down
there when you get down there sometime
man just to see if you could you know
introduce you to some other riders and
just hear you guys chat and think no go
down with so I'm gonna do a road trip
it'd be cool man it'd be really cool we
have a to questions that have come in
Nick did you have any um did you have
any questions you don't have to have it
either
I did notice you don't wear a wedding
ring and I was just wondering if that
was like I don't know cuz a lot of times
I've heard a wedding ring attracts other
women so maybe if you're in an open
relationship you wear it it's best of
both worlds but I have a [ __ ] ring big
diamond on it really get those kind of
sharp them that explains ya know I yeah
I don't I don't do jewelry yeah yeah
right on yeah I don't have one either
but that's cuz nobody I mean somebody
wants me probably but I just don't know
I don't know if it's an old idea but I
don't know if I no one's ever offered me
one either and I have the worst fingers
you look at that yeah yeah I broke this
one a couple of years ago I'm not sure
yeah even I mean oh if it were just
rattle on there my fingers so skinny or
just kind of rattle against the bone we
have two questions from callers that
came in and one is just you want to go
ahead with one name yeah here's the
first one hey you you can call me me
from Saudi Arabia I have been dealing
with depression and anxiety too for
maybe seven eight months probably more I
don't know but I can't visit or see a
therapist here because you know they're
very expensive and what have hurt they
are very bad but honestly I don't know
why I'm making this thought but maybe
you can give me an advice or something
that will make this more bearable
because I had suicidal thoughts for
quite a while now
I still question like why would someone
keep on going when life is pretty [ __ ]
and that's good yeah it can be very bad
here so would you like we get calls like
this sometimes you know dar holler and
we get tons of all types of calls and
and I just thought I would what would
you say to somebody like that that calls
you know and just uh I'm not first thing
I'd say is I'm not qualified I'm not a
clinical psychologist right yeah and I'm
not trying to put any onus on you I know
that you know this isn't you know
licensed advice or anything right right
yeah it's it's very hard because um you
know she said she can't afford a
therapist and maybe therapist I don't
know anything about therapy in Saudi
Arabia so I can't I you know I don't
know anything about the situation but
right she's got suicidal thoughts and
extreme anxiety and depression it's
important to talk to somebody it's
important not to try to go through that
alone I think yeah and if she could find
a good therapist what they would be
trying to help her do is to first to
find the source of these feelings right
and whether it's in her family dynamics
or you know it can be coming from lots
of different places and then - once it's
identified - try to reframe it in a way
that she feels more of a sense of
control so I like that so she's not as
like a victim of it as much as she's a
part of it yeah yeah I mean uh for
example I have a friend in Spain who did
his PhD research on psychotherapy but we
assisted with MDMA mm-hmm
which is also known as ecstasy or Molly
or whatever it's very useful in in
psychotherapy because it
reduces the anxiety and the fear of the
person who takes it so once you've
established a rapport with a therapist
and then you can take some MDMA and have
therapy it enables the person to talk
about a traumatic experience so he
specializes in working with women who've
suffered from sexual trauma hmm and they
haven't responded to any other type of
therapy Wow and his success rates are
incredible that's dynamite yeah and what
he's doing with them is is see the thing
about PTSD is that people are afraid to
face the experience the memory so it
pops aw it comes up in dreams it
manifests physiologically and digestive
issues or skin problems or back pain or
lots of different ways but like so many
other things in life the only way to get
past it is to go through it you're never
gonna run away from it ya ever gonna get
away so you have to turn and face it but
that's really hard because it's become
this giant monster chasing you you know
and MDMA can help people turn and so
they turn and they react speery insist
they get back into what happened whether
it was with you the rape or the the war
trauma or whatever it was and they are
they're able to reframe the experience
now because they're re experiencing it
but with a sense of control and so from
that point on in their lives they
remember it differently and let some of
the air out of the balloon you know it
drains some of the power out of the
experience so you know getting to this
person we don't know what is the source
of these feelings but it's important not
to go through this alone so if she can't
afford a therapist or can't find a
therapist I hope she'll at least talk
about this stuff in depth with a good
friend yeah yeah yeah I think that's a
good start especially like since you
know it's far away if I'm sure they're
probably friends or someone who can help
you find somebody local
yeah if we find a resource or something
that we see it we can find a general
like Saudi Arabia or Middle Eastern
resource then we'll put a couple links
up you know you remind me these days a
lot of people are doing therapy online
so maybe she's not limited to Saudi
Arabia it's a good point if she can call
us someone online and if she can listen
to the pot then we'll put a link up as
well young lady to see if there's some
online opportunities we'll see what we
can find we're not gonna promise but
we'll try yeah we had one more call that
came in that we thought maybe you could
be helpful with and I know that was
general I was just thinking you know
maybe with depression and stuff but I
certainly appreciate you yeah my wife's
a psychiatrist and she's actually
thinking about the reason I know this
thing about online is she's thinking
about starting to do therapy online
because you know we live all different
places yeah the world and let us know
we'd love to try and render some
clientele if we you know who know yeah
yeah it's it's an interesting world we
hit him with the off-speed stuff first
this one's definitely more in your
wheelhouse
okay I'm from California 27 year old I'm
struggling with you know the topic of
monogamy you know so but pretty much
marry we have a four-year-old daughter
together but we don't have sex very much
or ever is that and you know I've been
you know hit the gym you know I've been
you know getting really fit and flex I'm
my confidence is skyrocketing there's
many women out there that I'm uh you
know that I see trying to talk to me and
stuff and I don't know what to do if I
should just you know do my do my thing
break things off I don't know that the
relationships kind of broken and feel
like you know we're not really in this
relationship together it kind of isn't
there for the kid I even brought up a
topic of you know open relationship and
part of me was broken part of me wasn't
she gave me the ultimatum of okay well
if you want to do that then does that
mean I get a sleeper those other dude
that's just his conundrum well and yeah
we're not asking anything specifically
it's not we would listen to the gather
buzz yeah no I mean I I feel like he got
to the moment of truth there and he
stopped like does it mean she gets to
sleep with other dudes cuz it sounds to
me like she's open to the idea right so
what's the problem so at that point he
needs to be if he believes that for
himself then he should be able to
believe that for her as well or out of
respect even right and then be able to
voice that right and that's probably
gonna be very scary to do because you
can have to be vulnerable there right
but again look at what look at this
essence of the vulnerability what what
are you afraid of you're gonna lose the
relationship sounds to me like you're
pretty much ready to walk away from it
anyway so what what's he really have to
lose right right that's a great point
you know it's like yeah it might feel
better to walk away or to cheat because
then your ego is protected yeah you're
in control of it yeah but you're you're
being you're lying you know and you're
[ __ ] up your daughter's life and
you're you know so and you're gonna be
living in those lies then then you're
gonna be carrying around lies and you're
gonna feel like a liar yeah and that's
not gonna make you feel good and then
you have this little girl growing up
with all this anger and distrust and you
know how else she gonna relate to men in
the future you know listening to her mom
cry and you know calling you a liar I
mean I think the thing is we we forgive
ourselves for lying because we think
we're avoiding hurting people mm but in
the end we hurt them worse hmm and we
hurt ourselves because you know you and
you're living a lie you know when you're
not real and being real is always better
I mean unless you're a [ __ ] pedophile
or something yeah and even then being
honest with yourself about what it is
you want to do will help you not do it
right
No wow man I don't think some of the
that's some of the truest stuff I've
ever heard man that we think we when we
lie that were protecting people or that
but we're actually gonna end up hurting
him more you know you know yeah so in
that in that case I would say you know
he got to the moment where she he raised
it with her and she's like okay is this
a two-way street and then he stopped
like if it is a two-way street then then
you guys could end up having a great
time that's true man it could be a full
waste you put up a four-way stop sign
you know it could become an intersection
yeah yeah I think just being able to be
brave in moments of communication is
just you know it's something that I mean
I think about all the time that I'm
learning about a my own life and I it's
just so great having here today to help
us think about some of this stuff man to
talk about it yeah it's super cool man
it's super super cool to have somebody
that's as able to communicate on a on a
regular man's level you know you don't
communicate to me like you're better
than me you know which I'm worse than we
really did an analysis no but I
appreciate it man it makes me feel it
doesn't because sometimes I think a lot
of guys feel afraid to you know not be
smart if they're afraid to talk to
somebody that's smarter than them
because that person is just gonna push
that they're smart and you're not that
they're also human and I think that that
makes people feel uncomfortable you know
yeah but you don't do that or to me you
don't man and well I'm not that smart
yeah anyway I don't know what I'm kind
of say I'm just trying to say thank you
thank you and that's what I'm trying to
say um yeah and it's it's also I mean to
blow some smoke your way I I one of the
best things that's happened in my life
since sexathon came out is somehow I've
gotten to hang out with comedians hmm a
lot and you know it just sort of feels
like a natural community and I'm sort of
like an honorary member some somehow and
yeah I [ __ ] love it I love it cuz
it's so it's like I was thinking on the
drive over here laughing he's like a
brain orgasm it
just happens you know it's a it's a
physiological reaction you have to
something it is a fascinating moment
yeah it's magical I mean I know you said
[ __ ] magic but I think it's real magic
it's not a trick you know and what I
love about hanging out with you guys is
you're so [ __ ] honest and I think
that's something I didn't realize when I
watched comics from a distance on TV or
whatever it's like ok they're performers
and it's an act but now that I've gotten
to know a a lot of comedians I realized
that the comedy comes out of courage of
being honest with yourself mm-hmm and
it's really it's [ __ ] it's an honor
for me to hang out with people like you
and Simon and Joe and Bryan Callen and
like you're all you all have that in
common you're all like really sincere
thoughtful people yeah it's great thanks
man
yeah I think that's a goal I think it's
if it's a goal but it's something that I
do want to be you know because I think
you know we need when I look back on
some of my life I don't always know if I
was that way not because I didn't want
to be because I was had created this
other you know like you said this
protective world where I don't know who
I was really but if you get stuck in
that world you run out of material yes a
hundred percent because the material is
in your fears what's funny only in the
last two years my comedy and my whole
life has changed so much I think yeah
and I think some of it is just because
I'm just trying to learn more about Who
I am and just trying to have feelings
yeah but it's been fascinating man you
know I got into sex at dawn and I
recommend this book to anybody like and
you know and I don't want anybody to
think that we're saying there that I'm
saying anyway that if you're in a
healthy successful marriage or anything
like that that you need to run around on
your spouse or or anything like that if
you're if you feel comfortable and you
guys are having a good time as far as
I'm concerned go and live your joy you
know in more power to you and I I think
that there's you know there's everybody
finds whatever works for them but if
you're out there and you're
uncomfortable then maybe some of this
conversation helped with some of that
made you think about some things this
book sex had done when I first started
reading it I listen I will listen to it
a lot but I didn't want to hear it at
first I shut it off after the beginning
because some of it to me felt kind of
anti-christian a little bit right and
I'm not judging you or anything but this
was the experience that I had but then I
thought to myself we'll do you're not
gonna you know you can't be an open
person if you don't listen to stuff and
if you don't and then I listened to it
and I loved it and I didn't think like
it was anti-christian I thought it was
it it made me just realize that there's
a lot of things in our path in our past
and in our lives and in our society and
in our evolution that have formed some
of the ways that we live now there
aren't even choices that I've made but
they're just kind of templates that I've
kind of fallen into or or that the river
of my existences has passed through
these certain banks that have always
been there and it made me just start to
think about things more and I don't feel
any different at the end but I do feel
like I have just more questions and I'm
more able to listen to new things and if
this was a fascinating read for me man
it was really really cool did it it
opened me up in more ways than I thought
there's a lot of stuff about
masturbation in there yeah well it's uh
look that's the dark arts dude I'm
trying to stay off of it we have the
gift for you too man one of these ribs
wallets so these things are dope dude I
didn't like mine at first but I loved it
and I didn't mean to knock your book at
home with money no money in there no
kind of wallet is this but they're
really really cool man it's just a new
type of wallet so it's like you so it's
just this basically right right you
don't have to keep it in your back
pocket anymore and you put it in your
front pocket right and at first I didn't
like about three days into it and I am
hooked now nice but we have a couple you
can choose from one that you like and uh
in all different colors yeah some
different assortment you have to take
one with you no thank you
what about the new property that you're
working on that you mentioned what's
that going to be
that's called civilized to death hmm and
it's sort of an expansion of some of the
things that we talked about inside
it's a look at how the animal that we
evolved to be is sort of out of place in
the modern world and it gets into some
of the stuff I said about distrusting
voices that tell you to question your
appetites you know to not listen to your
your body because I think the basically
the story we've been told is that human
beings are these horrible monsters and
we need society culture to keep us in
check so we don't kill each other and
you know rape and pillage and it's the
Thomas Hobbes who said that before the
state the human life was solitary poor
nasty brutish and short
right that's propaganda it's wrong
there's no scientific basis for any of
that so if the books in a relation of
what kind of animal is a human being
what kind of species are we yeah and to
what extent is civilization a benefit or
a detriment to our our existence mm-hmm
yeah it's interesting because the even
when I was listening to sex at dawn I
was like mile some of the you know some
of the ways from the past we couldn't
put on to now they wouldn't fit you know
like if we wanted to live you know a lot
would have to change if we wanted to
live more to possibly what our nature is
well yes and no I mean the way I look at
it is we live in an artificial world
there's no way around that with seven
and a half billion people on the planet
there's no way we're all gonna just be
hunter-gatherers or something that's not
going right so we live in a zoo right
but do you want to live in the San Diego
Zoo or the Calcutta Zoo Yeah right like
we can design an artificial environment
and cut us in India somewhere listen
yeah is it yeah and it's a shitty zoo
yeah it's just cages Yeah right and most
that we're unlocked too I bet but you
know you go to San Diego Zoo and they
design the enclosures with an
understanding of what kind of animal
hmm they don't just stick them in a cage
and you know throw some food in there
yeah so we can design our artificial
worlds to replicate the world in which
we evolved as a species so we can design
our relationships for example one of the
things that makes people feel really
good as you were commenting earlier with
your a experience is helping people yeah
so that's part of our nature so if
you're feeling depressed and
disconnected one of the best things you
can do is just go help people go
volunteer somewhere at a hospital at a
clinic work with animals work with kids
lots of people need help and it'll help
you to help them yes so it sounds like
oh that's mother Teresa [ __ ] it's
not that comes from an understanding of
what kind of animal Homo sapiens is
right that's true sleep is really
important you're telling yourself you
can get by in four hours of sleep at
night you're full of [ __ ] you can't
you're an animal you're an animal that
needs between seven and nine hours of
sleep every night that's just the way it
is yeah just like you need a certain
amount of aerobic exercise to be healthy
you need a certain diet these things
can't be ignored so understanding what
kind of an animal Homo sapiens is is
essential for designing a life that's
gonna be fulfilling mmm yeah it's
fascinating man yeah I never I never
wanted to know I think we're at a place
in history where a lot of people want to
start to know more about you know who we
are and get the most out of their life I
think we're I think we've come to the
end of the road really yeah Wow um get
out I'd love to just have you back
sometime and talk about just that yeah
sure
cuz I yeah I have a million thoughts on
that I'd love to get into it but is that
okay with you sure if we do it some
other time
cuz Ryan thank you so much we'll share
uh we'll share all your links and and
everything and uh I'm just I'm happy to
meet a friend of a friend man
yeah me too yeah thank you now I'm just
floating on the breeze and I feel up
tall and like these leaves I must be but
when I reach that round I'll share this
peace of mind I can feel it in my
thought it's gonna take
little time for me to sell that parking
brake and let myself
[Music]